hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga except for today because this is
just a quick announcement to let you
know that i have started another channel
it's called team pokemon and it aims to
cover the world of pokemon
in much the same way that we do here
just with one slight
massive difference really which is that
i am now the manager of a local pokemon
trying to sell you the pokemon in
question so it has a much more comic
focus than groundline review or new
world review
and i recommend that you click that link
thingy in the description right now and
head over to become one of the very
first subscribers and regardless of
where you fall on the pokemon spectrum i
guarantee that this channel is for you
unless you don't fall on the spectrum at
all i suppose in which case but you
don't need to have seriously played the
games or kept up with the anime all you
really need to do is listen to a 30 year
old man passively aggressively discuss
his childhood whilst trapped in the
nightmare of retail work
and of course this will in no way affect
new world review which will still remain
operational with regular hunt hunt
content uploaded straight into your
youtube feed but with that said i would
still love to see you over at team
pokemon
for some heavily increased shenanigans
so once again the link to the new
channel is in the description below i
look forward to seeing you there but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time